on this Friday night the charity the
payments the Prime Minister and the
demands for answers a conflict of
interest or worthy of a criminal
investigation and multiple probes into
Justin Trudeau's family ties to the weed
charity that is not just given members
of the Trudeau family a platform but a
paycheck as well signs of recovery
unemployment drops a bit in Canada but
why are women less likely to be back at
work situation critical in the u.s.
every day it seems like another record
as new cases of kovat 19 spiked deaths
in some hotspots begin to rise too from
a museum to a mosque the decision that
will transform this UNESCO World
Heritage Site in Turkey and think before
you flush a smelly situation with wet
wipes clogging urban sewers
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
what was an attempt to connect students
with volunteer work through the we
charity is blowing into a big political
crisis for Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
a number of probes are now underway
including an Essex investigation and now
the opposition conservatives are asking
the RCMP to look into it it's very clear
that there is there is sufficient
grounds for this matter to be
investigated by the police we have a
nearly 1 billion dollar sole source
contract awarded by the Prime Minister
and we know that there are there are
significant financial benefits that have
been received by the family of the Prime
Minister totaling more than three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars that
money was appearance fees paid by the
charity to Trudeau's mother and brother
his wife Sophie was also given a small
fee despite those close ties Trudeau did
not recuse himself from the decision to
give we the contract to administer 900
million dollars in student volunteer
work that contract has since been pulled
but as David akin explains the demands
for answers have just begun well Donna
Parliament's ethics commissioner is
already investigating there are calls
for the Auditor General to do the same
and not one but two House of Commons
committees will spend the summer
investigating but that's not enough for
the federal conservatives they want the
Mounties called in it's now essential
that we have a criminal investigation
into this matter the tipping point for
the Tories new revelations that Justin
Trudeau's mother Margaret received three
hundred and twelve thousand dollars from
we and Trudeau's brother Alexandra
received $40,000 money paid for speaking
engagements over the last several years
but all while Trudeau was Prime Minister
even Trudeau's wife Sophie got a $1,200
check from we for an event in 2012
before Trudeau was p.m. it's an
organization that is not just given
members of the Trudeau family a platform
but a paycheck as well so that's why we
think at war
it's this level of investigation and
there are new questions for members of
Trudeau's cabinet one of Finance
Minister Bill Morneau daughters is an
employee of we and another of his
daughters has spoken for free at a we
event Morneau's office said that did not
factor into the government's decision
and he did not recuse himself from
discussions about we despite his
family's connections so did anyone in
cabinet raised any red flags about the
deal did ministers know about the money
we was paying Trudeau's family they're
not saying any discussions that take
place in cabinet as you're fully aware
of our subject to cabinet
confidentiality and in any event it was
the civil service who told Cadman to do
the deal with we the directions that we
take are really based on the nonpartisan
advice that we get from our public
servants they made a very clear
recommendation Global News asked the 34
other members of the cabinet if they
knew about the Trudeau Families
connection do we not one even
acknowledged our questions if I were in
a cabinet minister sitting on that table
I would be very upset if this was kept
hidden from me and I signed off on
something without all that information
knowing that now as for the Prime
Minister himself he has had no public
events since news broke of his family's
connection to we and has yet to answer
any questions on the matter Donna and
David where does this leave the 900
million dollars student grant program
well the government website is up and
running it is taking applications from
charities and nonprofits who have vacant
positions and it's taking applications
from students those applications will be
taken up to August 21st right now
about 35,000 students have applied for
about 23,000 vacancies positions like
social media ambassador food bank clerk
senior citizens assistants and so on
none of these pay a wage but if you
complete a certain number of hours
volunteering Ottawa will send you a
check at the end of the summer worth up
to $5,000
Donna okay David in Ottawa thank you
billions of dollars in federal emergency
aid has been given to individuals and
businesses to help keep them afloat
during this pandemic and about 3 million
people have lost their jobs now there's
some signs of recovery the economy is
experiencing much bigger bounce-back
than forecast stats Canada data shows
more than 950 thousand jobs were added
in June as restrictions began to ease
and businesses reopened the jobless Lake
rate does remain at twelve point three
percent though that's down from the
record high of thirteen point seven
percent in May hardest hit in terms of
job losses have been women as Mike gelée
reports they're not returning to work as
quickly as men are it is on the surface
good news a gain of almost a million
jobs but economists warn these were the
easy ones and when they take a closer
look at the numbers they find they don't
add up because men are returning to work
in far greater numbers and
mathematically speaking there just
aren't enough men to fill the breach of
all the jobs that women have left behind
and if women don't start getting
reemployed again soon and household
spending will go down and that means GDP
will go down economists have taken to
calling it a she session certainly the
unemployment rate for women is higher
than for men but it's the
underutilization number which combines
those who are unemployed those who want
a job it didn't look for one and those
working half the regular hours where the
disparity is most obvious part of that
comes down to traditional household
roles with women taking on the majority
of home schooling during the pandemic
add in daycare issues for summer camps
and more uncertainty around schooling in
the fall women are feeling more pressure
than ever I think a woman's recovery is
everyone's recovery and I think given
the roles that they play I think in
health care is one of the things that
really stands out but not just health
care think about all the ways that we
live and how important women's work is
we need to see women do well just period
the Canadian Federation of Independent
Business released its numbers this week
as well the good part is that with 56
percent of businesses open there's room
for improvement the bad is that only 1/3
are back to full staff and merely a
quarter are seeing pre-pandemic revenues
a large part of why they're hearing from
their members is that fewer women are
returning to their old jobs we are
hearing that
there are some obstacles for women who
still are do a lot of the childcare in
the home and so I think that that
getting that piece of it right is going
to be critical
the alternative is an economy operating
and far less than optimal levels
microlight Global News Toronto the jobs
numbers also show young people aged 15
to 24 been hard hit the youth
unemployment rate is twenty seven point
five percent and for the first time
beginning next month stats Canada will
begin collecting information on race and
visible minority status as part of its
jobs report the agency says it
recognizes the social economic and labor
market impacts of kovat 19 have not been
felt equally by all Canadians in Quebec
an outbreak of Kovach 19 has made masks
mandatory inside public spaces in two
communities south of Montreal
it's believed a large house party is
linked to a series of infections that
for several businesses to close new
rules for bars are also now in effect to
help stop the spread and cluding a ban
on dancing and a 1:00 a.m. closing time
Quebec is the province hardest hit by
the virus with more than 56,000 cases in
Edmonton three more people at the
Misericordia hospital have now died
because of a growing outbreak there that
brings the total deaths to six another
16 patients and 16 staff have tested
positive for the virus the hospital is
closed to new patients surgery has been
cancelled and day procedures have been
shifted to another hospital Newfoundland
and Labrador has confirmed its first
case of koban 19 in more than a month it
is a man in his 50s who recently
returned from the United States public
health officials say he did not travel
through any of the other Atlantic
provinces and he did self isolate we
continue to look south where outbreaks
of Kovan 19 in many US states are
growing at record speed hospitalizations
are rising to intensive care units are
filling up and though the number of
people dying has been relatively stable
that too is starting to tick up in the
hardest hit cities Jackson prosecco
reports
across the u.s. the scale of the
pandemic is dizzying Alabama recorded
its highest one day rise in cases and
the most deaths in a single day 10,000
kovat 19 patients are now hospitalized
in Texas the morgues are filling up to
the coal bid 19 hours in the city quite
frankly in the state the side of control
and what we do today and over the next
few weeks is critical 15 states have
outbreaks that ranked among the worst in
the world worse than many countries our
positivity rates are up hospitalization
rates are up and our death rates are up
in Florida where 11,000 people tested
positive in just the past 24 hours ICU
beds are increasingly in short supply
area and yet Disneyworld pushed ahead
with reopening with limited crowds masks
and social distancing along for the ride
I was a little surprised and concerned I
think it's like pouring gasoline on a
fire at the same time President Donald
Trump traveled to the state to a County
where the case positive rate is a
staggering 33 percent but made only
brief mention of the virus we're still
fighting it and we're gonna do very well
Trump is increasingly distanced from the
reality of the pandemic and has
reportedly not asked for a briefing from
America's leading infectious disease
expert dr. Anthony Fauci
in two months when you compare us to
other countries I don't think you can
say we're doing great I mean we're just
not polls show two-thirds of Americans
feel the same way disapproving of
Trump's handling of the crisis as they
face the grim reality day after day
while Trump's top coronavirus advisors
now admit the worst is yet to come with
the death toll certain to rise again in
the coming weeks the president continues
to tout the national death rate as a
sign of success it's lower than it was
at its peak but has started to tick back
up in recent days and the regional
picture is much more grim with many
states setting daily records for
fatalities Donna Jackson prosecco in
Washington thanks the u.s. is trapped
this waiting game now the worst of the
pandemic is still expected to come
Jackson takes a deeper look at just how
bad it could get on our website global
news dot CA / global national in Quebec
an Amber Alert is still in effect for
two young girls who police believed was
more taken by their father that man's
partner has issued an emotional plea in
French for their safe return nothing
thank you
only but you better do fighting through
tears she says she's not heard from her
partner and just wants to know the girls
are okay
police say six-year-old Romy
Carpentier's and 11 year old Nora
carpenter went missing Wednesday night
they were last seen in the city of La
Vie south of Quebec City investigators
say the girls were most likely abducted
by their father 44 year-old Martin
Carpentier police believed the three may
have been involved in a car crash the
car was left abandoned anyone with
information is asked to call 911 mark
ruling in turkey coming up why turkey is
turning at this renowned museum back
into a mosque
a Turkish Court has ruled one of the
most famous ancient buildings in the
world should be converted back into a
mosque and shortly after that Turkey's
president signed a decree declaring the
Hagia Sophia opened to Muslim worship
[Applause]
the Hagia Sophia is a treasured site for
both Muslims and Christians it's nearly
1500 years old it was an Orthodox
Christian Cathedral for its first 900
years then became a mosque for the next
500 it became a museum in 1934 when
Turkey became a secular country today
turkeys most visited attraction has
increased security and there are
concerns the decision to return it to a
mosque may divide Christians and Muslims
in Paris France Notre Dame Cathedral
will be rebuilt in its original Gothic
style that's according to the French
president Emmanuel macron last year
flames gutted the Cathedral and
destroyed its spire Macra pushed for a
more modern design of the rebuild spire
but traditionalists one in the 12th
century monument will be restored to
what's called its complete coherent and
known state it's hope North freedom will
open for mass by 2024 Venice has
conducted a trial run of its
long-delayed anti flood barriers the
city is testing 78 inflatable barriers
meant to hold back high tides that flood
Venice almost every year compressors are
being used to pump air into the barriers
which rise and act as a kind of dike on
demand officials hope the system will be
ready for use later this year last
November Venice had its worst flooding
in 50 years
still ahead tick-tock trouble is the
social media phenomenon a cybersecurity
threat
because he hasn't taken any cognitive
test because he couldn't pass one I
actually took one when I very recently
when I when I was you know the radical
left was saying is you all there is you
all there and that's comedian Sarah
Cooper who's lip-synchs of President
Trump posted on tick-tock are watched by
millions and put her on the path to
stardom the social media platform tick
tock is wildly popular it has about 800
million monthly active users and the app
has been downloaded over 2 billion times
worldwide but beneath the pop culture
fun are big red flags about security
tick tock is chinese-owned and there are
concerns it can sweep up user data as
Jeff sample reports the Trump
administration fears it could be a
threat to national security when the
kovat 19 pandemic hit this Toronto Area
teen found herself stuck at home and
spending a lot of time on tick-tock the
social media app allows users to upload
and edit short video clips and a new
survey found it's used by more than half
of Canadians under 25 once you're on
it's really hard to stop because there's
so much content since she started
posting daily videos in March her
following has skyrocketed from a few
hundred to more than a hundred thousand
I'm have followers from people all
around the world I have people from
Australia and Germany and all these
other places but some of those countries
and companies are now reaching for the
delete button because of where
tick-tocks company is headquartered tick
tock is a Chinese owned company and and
so they're obliged to the Chinese
government and to provide any data that
the Chinese government should happen to
request like a lot of apps tik-tok
collects user data such as location and
device information but it was also
recently revealed that the app was
collecting a user's clipboard data such
as text that was copied and pasted in
other apps let's say you're you're
copying and pasting things back and
forth
tick tock was then able to read that
information
earlier this month India announced it
was banning TechTalk and the u.s. is
threatening to follow suit would you
recommend that people download that up
on their phones tonight tomorrow anytime
currently only if you want your private
information in the hands of the Chinese
Communist Party in a statement to Global
News a tik-tok spokesperson said we have
no higher priority than promoting a safe
and secure app experience for our users
we have never provided user data to the
Chinese government nor would we do so if
asked a lot of this I think also have to
do with the diplomatic and geopolitical
game and shift between the US and China
and the Canadian government has no plans
to ban the app and a spokesperson for
the Ministry of Public Safety says the
Canadians can be confident in the work
performed by our security agencies to
keep us safe and as long as the app is
available my Eliot says young Canadians
will continue to use it
Jeff sample global news Toronto up next
how fighting the pandemic is clogging up
our pipes
you may have heard the phrase save your
pipes don't flush the wipes it's
especially important as we sanitize our
way through this pandemic we're using
more wipes now than ever before
and too many are ending up being flushed
down the toilet as crystal commencing
explains that's resulting in some
disgusting blockages every second
roughly six thousand litres of sewage
flows into the mountain treatment plant
one of the largest sewer facilities in
the United Kingdom every aspect of the
operation on these 56 plus hectares can
be broken down and recited by Deena
Gillespie there are many challenges when
it comes to servicing two million
customers but this what's called rag is
one of the biggest issues and the
pandemic made it worse we've been
tracking the use of the problem of wet
wipes in the network and before lockdown
we saw a reduction of up to ten percent
but during lockdown we saw an increase
of up to ten percent so a difference
overall of about 20% during lockdown wet
wipes are being used in huge quantities
by people in London and around the world
when there was a run on toilet paper
more personal wipes were used the
antibacterial ones are also hugely
popular for everything from disinfecting
your groceries to sanitizing surfaces
now if you're thinking but I use the
ones that say biodegradable and
flushable that idea flies in the face of
what seen daily by workers here we've
got HCI you these so that's just one
that's just one in a type we call it rag
but it's a combination of wet wipes
sanitary product cotton buds plastics
that shouldn't be flushed down a toilet
you can see it's it's all clogged up
there's bits of fat in it as well and
it's it's material that is not
biodegradable look at this this is this
is a wet way that somebody's flush down
the toilet
looking through the tangled glob of
waste you can see many wet wipes fat
binds to them and they cause blockages
at the plant and at people's homes since
April the UK's largest water and waste
services company Thames Water has
received about 15 extra calls about
blocked sewer lines a day the only
things that should be flushed down a
toilet are P poo and paper everything
else Bennett don't block it as that
message gets shared the situation is
improving still nearly 10 tons of dried
rag is shipped to the landfill from this
site daily Krystal commencing Global
News London
yuck
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Donna freeze and we leave you
tonight with two stunning parts of
Atlantic Canada just recognized as
UNESCO global Geoparks Nova Scotia's
Cliffs of Fundy were given international
recognition for their unique geological
significance and rock formations and
fossils on the Bonavista Peninsula and
LU Finland and Labrador are now
preserved in the discovery global
Geopark thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye bye
[Music]